imagine the Sun is a very big issue for
many Australians they're fair-skinned so
they got to cover up and be safe I want
to be safe too
that's why I came here to the store with
the worst name I've ever seen Cancer
Council why not just call it Mike's
melanoma Hut this is Elvis yes and you
are the manager yep it's very important
for the Australian people to cover up is
that right absolutely what are we
thinking well I am a c-cup I just there
Barry I work out a lot what shall I work
out what's the word I'm thinking of
masculine no no no what do you guys call
these in Australia Wobblies these are
lovelies Wobblies no this is this is
Dagon excuse me what are these called
right here I look like someone from the
future I think we're getting there
look like I'm here to well the pipe
fully protected there if you ever get
the sense that we're not supposed to
live on earth
what's the sun protection that you
recommend for someone like me I'd
probably recommend that one there where
do I put it
are you gonna try and put it on your
fingers I want to put it I want to
protect his finger so when I'm you know
get the eyebrows get the eyebrows and
really put it on give me a little goatee
right here and I look like an albino
Colonel Sanders
I'm ready for the beach I think you are
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here on Bondi Beach the Sun is
incredibly hot and I just found this
little boy what's your name
Eddie Terry Terry looks exactly like me
in 1969
Barry no you shouldn't be here
Terry this is what you're gonna look
like when you get older if you don't do
something now this you want to look like
this after saving Terry's life I decided
to train to be a Bondi Beach lifeguard
with pop Oh Jethro and whippin three the
stars of Australia's long-running hit
reality show Bondi rescue what's the
most important thing for me to know to
be a lifeguard probably have a swim that
no okay that's gonna be a problem
oh but nicknames yeah you know I don't
really have a nickname Fanny pants you
guys put sunblock on all the time yeah
yeah well what's good about it you're
caring about it one of the conditions
anytime I go on a beach I bring my
personal dermatologist right there to
see that is that a problem no we'll take
we'll keep looking at it we'll keep an
eye on it very good you checkout any
ladies in those glasses dr. Peeters it
helps hey guys we need a nickname for
dr. Peters what do you think we're in
those glasses I'll give you creepy
creepy P so yeah I just want to learn
how to be a lifeguard it will take years
to become a lifeguard it takes a whole
lifetime of being in the ocean and
getting comfortable taste something I
think that's bull I'd like to just get a
nice montage out of this a good-looking
Bondi rescue montage you think we could
do that yeah sure yeah so the best
specialty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]